hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play Vapor now
you guys have given me some good
suggestions about what I need to do and
what the power-ups are so the original
green thing allowed me to shoot green
fireballs out of my butt and then the
red things are health the blue swirlies
are faster speedy uppers and then the
blue shiny do was I don't know an
upgrade to the weapon either way what I
need to do is I need to collect these
artifacts and combine them with the
things I find so like in the initial
here I found a hand sticking out of the
ground then I need to go find the
complimenting artifact and there are
three different monsters and I don't
know what the hell I'm talking about you
all shut up I don't know what I'm doing
I'm just gonna keep running and shoot
things in the face it seems like our
first-person shooter this Call of Duty
ghost
hahaha I know that was it no shut up
everybody okay whatever
oh you I remember you I'm gonna shoot
the piss out of you hey wait come here
we got a bone to pick with you get it
cut yeah alright kaboom you son of a
[ __ ] get back in the ground there okay
I got it I think I got it I got it right
then they I may have gotten it I don't
know I think I got it
now my strategy is gonna be bunny
hopping until I get back to the campfire
and then I see where the next thing is
on my map due to its glowy nature and my
friend should be coming out of the woods
any minute now buddy I get off of me
buddy
I hear you oh not you
got it ah friend Oh get out of there it
is I saw that you can't have for me
ah rocks no okay we're good why is that
that's bull you let me get caught on
rocks you son of a [ __ ] that's kind of
not fair okay well that was stupid
you're dumb and you should feel dumb for
being dumb used to feel bad about being
stupidness cuz me marks so much smarter
than you at games and stuff okay
nevermind why wasn't that too far so
I'll just start over not get stuck on
rocks that next time it's ours just not
my fault maybe that was punishment for
making a Call of Duty reference ah yeah
whatever who cares whatever let's just
go on all right get the fireballs Sargon
shoot him out of my butt
had all enemies like this one poppin on
the ground are da [ __ ] okay so now you
son of a [ __ ] yeah good good okay so
yeah yeah I know I see it it's right in
front of my face I know I know it's
there OOP there's another one but now I
know that I need to go to the right
after I go to the campfire so I don't
necessarily need to go to the campfire I
could just kind of go off to the right
and avoid the rocks and then go on my
merry way until I home get off of my
ankles just stupid son of a gun yeah the
way you died that's right caboose
alright so where is it
well there's my friend coming up to see
me give me a great big hug where is it
oh there it is okay so I gotta avoid
whatever he does that that's really
annoying right there oh uh yeah yes
thanks for showing me all those home
movies but I don't see them right now
I'm gonna get this artifact and then
blow you up or not I don't know how this
works really here we go this is what I'm
done
hey he's behind me can you not can you
not could you not when he's right behind
me okay I got rapid fire you sons a
[ __ ] get away get away get away you
don't get away get away get away get
away get away get away get away get away
get away get away
well like I rapid-fire but I have no
reason to use it on yo boom headshot
yeah okay enough celebrating shut up
I still got rapid fire for the time
being what none of you're gonna blow up
there we got her - and a burn
come on the hand combine the cross no
that Ghost should be gone forever right
that's how this works right
until I pick up oh okay yeah you're dead
are you better me haha was that your
last death throes okay that ghost is now
dead or witch or whatever it is I don't
know what it is
haha but it's dead and now I find the
next okay here we go I got an amulet of
sorts what do I combine this way go I
don't like you stupid oh no it's the
blue I need that damn you tons of
mothers mother hubbard hi can you not
could you not ha ha
super speedy alright look at me okay so
where's aha
there it is okay so now I go find this
next thing combine them Burnham I wish I
could have another speedy do fireball
isn't very effective what I got [ __ ] ton
million of these things on my ass I hope
I'm still going in the right direction
wouldn't even able to look oh is it the
thing on the hill
wait no no it's not that's right ah
goddamnit going okay okay there's still
a thing
chasing me
could you're not good you're not could
you not wait I didn't pick it up the
ribcage there why am I so slow god damn
it get off of me
ah they're not good you're not
okay good I thought I was dead there I
asked nicely
if you could not and you do you do it
over and over again you stupid sons of
[ __ ] I'm gonna murder y'all boom bang
IBAMA bye boom okay I miss it I miss it
oh yeah
there we go burn burn burn burn burn
burn burn burn [ __ ] burn that's right
that's what I'm talking about
get off of me who's who's still
crunching me sorry sorry lady now you're
dead okay
I think I get this I think I got it so
now I just need to get the thing and not
come back to the park cuz that was my
mistake it came back to the fire first
when I was supposed to go away to the
next artifact location so I need to do
my bunny hopping super mountain climbing
skills and then I'll get along and then
go to my thing dude a mountain I'm going
to dominate you heard ah good luck
little right now come on come on
you get some yeah all right yeah all
right come on oh I'm so close come on
I'm so close oh you son of a [ __ ] I'm
right here Oh fine you know what I'll go
this way so you're gonna be a little
douche about this and oh come on
how did I get up before was I over here
oh yeah I came down to this rock cuz is
where you're supposed to get up that's
right I'm an idiot
huh I forgot that I had already found Oh
actual way up my pad whatever okay get
off of my flat piss outta Yeti
what No BAM insta-kill
get off of me you sons of [ __ ] wow
that really hurt
okay pick up this thing did I get it I
got it
get off of me I'm gonna get I'm off this
nut no do not kill me you son of a [ __ ]
if you kill me
I'm fine now now not right into him what
the BOK I'm not dead Oh God I was dead I
thought I was dead
you [ __ ] god dammit you piece of [ __ ]
mother humping
son of a gun blasts turd [ __ ] you
alright I'll be back ah okay we are back
I had to actually go first why shut up
your stubborn mother number I will
murder you dead you stay dead okay now
I'm not even going the right way am i
glad I don't care I actually had to go
through it twice which is really
annoying because these stupid goobie
Glauber thingamabob errs the the weirdo
ones the skull and spine and pelvis
thrusting ones they ganged up on me it
wasn't fair it was totally cheap I
didn't deserve to die that way
in fact I didn't deserve to die at all
and yet they still killed me I mean do
they know who I am
I'm markiplier or at least I think I am
maybe I'm not anymore maybe that's just
the old me and no idea frankly I don't
care don't care don't care I want my
insta-kill so that I can blow those
things away get at me I know you're
bluffing there's a French rap rap screw
you guys
screw you hard
yeah it's kind of weird okay anyway just
grab this thing have it scream at me now
get off of me
no no no you're not gonna kill me not
this time
oh why no no give me the help give me
the help
well that was stupid
one down yeah it only took ten tries but
here I am in the winner's circle I'm
gonna get it at nobody to get its Dhabi
this is it [ __ ] ridiculous but I
don't care anymore
I'm so tired of playing this game i have
literally been at this for the past hour
trying to get this because it's just oh
man i cannot stand this i can hardly
stand to play this anymore this is
absolutely freakin ridiculous good I'm
getting all healed up I might actually
be at full frickin health that would be
amazing
Java me no no no no okay what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna grab this i'ma go off
that edge I'm gonna jump cuz I know it's
that way
yeah yeah yeah who cares
was so disturbing ah get off of me get
off of get the [ __ ] off of me you get
off of me you sons of [ __ ]
No god damn you out yeah oh yeah right
value you haven't got me I know you have
it oh god I'm almost dead no no give me
a help give me some help
give me some goddamn ow
[ __ ] me gah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it I don't
want it [ __ ] you and [ __ ] all you [ __ ]
you to hell
oh god what a fricking hard